wie spricht ich gegen einen allgemeinen
Lockdown aus und auch gegen eine
Impfpflicht Christine aschenberg-dugnus
und zugeschaltet die FDP
Gesundheitspolitik gerinn und
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin guten
Morgen
guten Morgen ausschließlich
Residence
weitere Einschränkungen obwohl ja
eigentlich noch gar nicht flächendeckend
hier ist
ja das ist richtig
ja ich sehe es so dass wir noch nicht
alles getan haben um die Mail zu
erreichen die ich noch nicht habe nehmen
zu lassen da Unterhalt dieses starken
Grundrechtseingriff seine allgemeine
Nebenpflicht ist noch viel zu tun wir
wissen von den Experten wo wir uns hin
wenden müssen Bremen z.b. hat gezeigt
dass man in die Quartiere reingehen kann
dass man mit direkte Ansprache dass man
echte nehmen muss und kann damit noch
erreichen dass ich mindestens 50%
diejenigen die noch nicht geimpft sind
dass man sie erreichen kann und man muss
ja auch sagen wir wissen ja noch so
wenig auch von covid-19 eine Impfpflicht
zu installieren eine allgemeine wo man
noch gar nicht weiß wie oft man geimpft
werden muss das gibt
verfassungsrechtlich erhebliche
Schwierigkeiten und in unserer 4. und 5.
Welle würde es auch überhaupt nicht mehr
haben wir viele Politiker sowie sie auch
schon gesagt und dann ihre Meinung
geändert werden sie wenn es eher zu der
Abstimmung im Bundestag kommt wo die
Abgeordneten vor allem Wissen und
Gewissen abstimmen können werden Sie
also gegen eine Impfpflicht stimmen
Wort das über uns ein Schwert wieder
fleißig wie geht's nach Weihnachten
weiter wird es eine Art Lockdown geben
und glauben Sie dass uns das jetzt noch
schützen kann
also die Maßnahmen die wir ja schon im
Infektionsschutzgesetz zur Verfügung
werden auf jeden Fall helfen die müssen
nur umgesetzt werden es ist jetzt nicht
die Zeit Bars und Clubs offen zu halten
ist es auch nicht die Zeit für
Großveranstaltungen und wir müssen eben
auch informieren darüber dass wenn man
nicht gepostet ist man auch ein
erhebliches Risiko hat an nomicon zu
erkranken das heißt wir müssen die
Booster Impfungen weiter vorantreiben
wir sind im Moment Spitze in Europa mit
der Anzahl der boosterimpfung das muss
über die Feiertage auch weiter umgesetzt
werden wir müssen weiter dafür werben es
ist ja jetzt genug Impfstoff vorhanden
weil ja noch mal zusätzlich bestellt
wurde und so können wir den Menschen
sagen wenn ihr alle boosterimpfung habt
habt ihr einen erheblichen Schutz auch
gegen Omikron da müssen wir also weiter
immer wieder weiter dafür werben und ich
danke an dieser Stelle auch all
diejenigen die über die Feiertage bereit
sind zu impfen und dort tätig zu sein
trotzdem dieses Katastrophenszenario
dass ich hier momentan im Rasen schnell
ausbreiten kann wie in den USA wo vor
einer Woche noch der Anteil bei 17% lag
und jetzt bei 73% müsste man nicht da
ein Lockdown doch noch in Betracht
ziehen der nordrhein-westfälische
Ministerpräsident Hendrik wüst hatte das
zumindest heute bei uns nicht
ausgeschlossen
also im Moment kann man überhaupt nichts
ausschließen
kann sie nicht ausschließen also ich
hoffe dass wir daran vorbeikommen das
wäre wirklich die absolute ultima ratio
1 Jahre hat glaube ich dass er das haben
wir immer gesagt wir hoffen dass wir
daran vorbeikommen und dann war es eben
doch so und man hat das Gefühl man
könnte jetzt zu diesen Zeiten genau in
dieses Szenario wieder rein schließende
gute rein schießen der gute Wille wird
betont wir hoffen es gibt keine Stühle
Schulschließungen der Garantie also
nicht geben
niemand kann irgendeine Garantie
haben
wir
dass sie sozial ins Abseits geraten die
Kinderpsychiatrie laufen gerade über
auch das müssen wir berücksichtigen und
deswegen ist wirklich eine
Schulschließung das aller allerletzte
und ich hoffe dass wir das nie wieder
machen müssen wir hoffen dass wir können
nichts ausschließen und niemand kann
eine Garantie geben Christina
aschenberg-dugnus vielen Dank für das
Gespräch